as the entire US government works to
combat the global pandemic it is
absolutely essential that the key
positions at relevant federal agencies
are fully staffed and we're not allowing
that to take place through our Congress
they're just not they're just not giving
it to us we have many many positions
that are unstaffed because we can't get
the approvals the Democrats are holding
us up we cannot get approval we've
gotten judges because we go through the
process I guess we're up to 448 federal
judges and that we've gotten because we
focus on it we take the maximum time
because no matter who the judges they
take vast numbers of days and hours till
provent leaves no time left for others
very unfair system if a judge is going
to be approved in one hour in one
session it doesn't matter they'll take
the maximum number of hours and days
you're talking about days to get one
judge approved and we're close to 250
judges but because of the way they're
doing it there's no time for anybody
else and many of these people have been
waiting for two and a half years we have
a couple that have been waiting for
longer than that they're currently 129
nominees stuck in the Senate because of
partisan obstruction many are nominated
for vacancies that must be filled to
assist with the coronavirus crisis and
the resulting economic challenges and
I've read over the couple of years well
I didn't fill positions I don't fill
positions in some cases we don't need
the position and I'm all for that
but in many cases you do but we can't
get them approved by the Democrats that
won't release the positions include the
Director of National Intelligence two
members of the Federal Reserve Board of
Governors the assistant secretary of
treasury for financial markets of the
United the United States and the Under
Secretary of Agriculture responsible for
administering food security programs and
sonny perdue who's going to be speaking
today saying please can I have this man
can I have this particular person
approved as soon as possible he's been
telling me that for a long time and the
Democrats won't allow it to happen again
every single judge every nominee we have
goes through maximum or at least they go
through a long process so it takes days
and days and there's no time left and
it's just a concerted effort to make
life difficult an example is Michael
pack
he's my nominee for the CEO of the
broadcasting broadcasting Board of
Governors has been stuck in committee
for two years preventing us from
managing the voice of America very
important and have you heard what's
coming out of the voice of America it's
disgusting
well things they say are disgusting
toward our country and Michael pack
would get any do a great job but he's
been waiting now for two years
can't get him approved the Senate has
left Washington until at least May 4th
the Constitution provides a mechanism
for the president to fill positions in
such circumstances the recess
appointment it's called the Senate's
practice of gaveling into so-called pro
forma sessions where no one is even
there has prevented me from using the
constitutional authority that we're
giving that we're given under the
recessed provisions the Senate should
either fulfill its duty and vote on my
nominees or it should formally adjourn
so that I can make recess appointments
we have a tremendous number of people
that have to come into government and
now more so than ever before because of
the virus and the problem we have to do
it and we have to do whatever we have to
do they've made it very very difficult
to run government I don't think any
administration has done anywhere near
what we've done in three-and-a-half
years but every block every week they
put up roadblocks whether it's Russia
Russia Russia or whether it's
impeachment hoax or whatever it
it's always roadblocks and a waste of
time if the house will not agree to that
adjournment I will exercise my
constitutional authority to adjourn both
chambers of Congress the current
practice of leaving town while
conducting phony pro forma sessions is a
dereliction of duty that the American
people cannot afford during this crisis
it is a scam what they do it's a scam
and everybody knows it and it's been
that way for a long time and perhaps
it's never done before it's never been
done before nobody's even sure if it has
but we're going to do it we need these
people here we need people for this
crisis and we don't want to play any
more political games I've been waiting
for two and a half years three years to
some of these people and they're great
people they left law firms they left
jobs they gave up everything to do it
and they've been waiting for three years
two and a half years two years one year
to get approved it's ridiculous and
everyone knows they're going to be
approved but there's only so many hours
in the day when you go through judges
and you go through lengthy hearings on
judges that they know should be approved
immediately and they could do it in one
session one and they could do it in one
hour and instead it takes some many days
in order to advance the health and
security of our nation and all nations
as we announced yesterday the US
government has put a hold on funding to
the w-h-o World Health Organization
pending a review of the organization's
coverup and mismanagement of the corona
virus outbreak over the objections of
the WHL we took decisive action and
early life-saving action to suspend
travel from China they didn't want to do
it they were angry that we did it it was
early on they were angry that we did it
took him a long time to realize what was
going but I have a feeling they knew
exactly what was going on
tragically other nations put their trust
in the WHL and they didn't do any form
of band
and you see what happened to Italy you
see what happened to Spain you see what
happened to France wh joe's guidance had
failed to control their borders at a
very crucial face quickly unleashing the
contagion around the world that was a
horrible tragic mistake or perhaps they
know I'm sure they didn't know the
gravity of it but perhaps they knew
because if they knew the gravity that
would be an even worse offence to ease
the economic pain of millions of
American families we've now processed
300 billion dollars in loans to more
than 1 million small businesses through
the Paycheck protection program this
action has saved millions of American
jobs it's been an incredible success and
they want to replenish it now but again
the Democrats don't want to do that this
is money that goes to the workers of our
country phase one was three hundred and
fifty billion dollars and now phase two
we want to do two hundred and fifty
billion this goes to workers and it goes
to small businesses so we can save all
the small businesses around our nation
Mike McFarland from Nebraska recently
said this historical relief has been a
godsend
for his small factory and the 136
Americans who work there save those jobs
another small business owner Tim Miller
from Oklahoma called the program a total
lifesaver fors auto repair shops for
employees stories like these underscore
why Congress must replenish the paycheck
protection program immediately the
Republicans want to do it they want to
do it immediately they want to do it now
and the Democrats are stopping it